manipulating people and manipulating
people but also
generative AI can manipulate the
manipulators
it can I mean there's there's many
layers of manipulation that are possible
and I think we don't yet really
understand the consequences Dan Dennett
just sent me a manuscript last night
that will be in the Atlantic in a few
days on what he calls counterfeit people
it's a wonderful metaphor these systems
are almost like counterfeit people and
we don't really honestly understand what
the consequence of that is they're not
perfectly human-like yet but they're
good enough to fool a lot of the people
a lot of the time folks welcome back to
mlst today is an incredibly special
episode because I got to interview
another one of my heroes doesn't happen
very often I mean my God a year ago it
was noim Chomsky and now it is Professor
Daniel Dennett he is easily the most
famous and well-known philosopher alive
today
um I just can't get my head around how I
managed to pull this thing off I was
implementing the winging it methodology
I saw Professor Gary Marcus talk about
Dennis new paper that we're going to
talk about at the Senate meeting a few
weeks ago I slowly reached for the
keyboard I started typing Dennis email
address the words the words came out I
pressed the send button minutes later
Professor Dennett replied
um you know I'm not going to detain us
too long on this particular thing but
um basically he said yes and this was an
opportunity that I was going to
capitalize on because then it is my hero
he is an absolute living legend so um
yeah this is this is going to go down
this is this is one of those things I
can tell my my grandchildren about
anyway
um enough enough of all of that let's
carry on with the show so um Professor
Daniel Dennett has just published an
article in the Atlantic called
counterfeit people
um he said in that article creating
counterfeit digital people risks
destroying our civilization
democracy depends on the informed not
misinformed consent of the government by
allowing the most economically and
politically powerful people corporations
and governments to control our attention
these systems will control us
counterfeit people by distracting and
confusing us and by exploiting our most
irresistible fears and anxieties will
lead us into temptation and from there
into acquiescing to our own subjugation
the counterfeit people will talk us into
adopting policies and convictions
that'll make us vulnerable to yet more
manipulation or will simply turn off our
attention and become passive and
ignorant pawns this is a terrifying
Prospect
Dennis spoke about anthropomorphizing
large language models now he thinks that
they don't have agency at the moment
although he doesn't think they have zero
agency but he thinks that we shouldn't
anthropomorphize them and we should be
wary of a scribing agency to them when
architecturally they don't have a
significant amount of agentiveness
although interestingly then it does
think that this is just an architectural
configuration there's no reason in
principle why they couldn't be
configured to have more Agency on that
note Dennis signed the AI risk letter
that letter was very short it said
mitigating the risk of Extinction from
AI should be a global priority alongside
other societal scale risks such as
pandemics and nuclear war
this episode is sponsored by numerai are
you a data scientist looking to make a
real world impact with your skills do
you love competing against the best
Minds in the world well introducing
numeri the Revolutionary cutting-edge AI
driven hedge fund that's changing the
game for good Numerica mines a
competitive data science tournament with
powerful clean stock market data
enabling you to predict the market like
never before and with over 26 million
dollars in NMR which is their
cryptocurrency already paid out to
brilliant data scientists like you it's
time to stake your claim to success now
when you log on you can collaborate with
a rapidly expanding Global Network you
can expand your skills and you can
control the capital of numerize hedge
fund the sky is the limit for your data
prowess join numeri today rise to the
challenge and help build the world's
last hedge fund sign up now become part
of the elite community taking the stock
market by storm and I'll see you on the
leaderboard anyway back to the show now
I would like to Prime you on a few
philosophical Concepts that we're going
to be discussing today the first of
which is the intentional stance so this
is a concept which was developed by
Professor Daniel Dennett and it refers
to a perspective or strategy in which we
interpret the behavior or actions of a
system such as a person an animal or
even a machine by attributing intentions
beliefs desires or other psychological
states to it now in this approach we
predict and explain the system's
Behavior by assuming it has goals or
desires which is to say the system's
actions aim to achieve specific outcomes
also beliefs the system has a mental
representation of the world which guides
its actions based on those beliefs and
finally rationality the system acts
rationally according to its beliefs and
desires to achieve its goals so the
intentional stance works as a heuristic
or explanatory framework to make sense
of the complex behavior of such systems
now Dennett proposed three stances to
understand and predict the behavior of a
system
the physical stance explains the
behavior based on the physical laws
governing the system like the laws of
physics or chemistry or biology there's
also the design stance which focuses on
the intended purpose or function of the
system often in terms of its engineering
or design principles
and finally the intentional stance which
attributes intentions beliefs and
desires to the system to explain Its
Behavior now another really important
concept I wanted to speak about is the
knowledge argument which comes up all
the time in philosophy of Mind
discussions it was originally proposed
by Frank Jackson and it goes as follows
Mary is a brilliant scientist who is for
whatever reason forced to investigate
the world from a black and white room
via a black and white television she
specializes in the neurophysiology of
vision and acquires all the physical
information there is to obtain about
what goes on when we see ripe Tomatoes
or the sky or use terms like red and
blue and green and so on
so what happens when Mary is released
from her black and white room does she
learn anything new or not well Jackson
claims that she does Mary's room is a
thought experiment which attempts to
establish that there are non-physical
properties and attainable knowledge that
can be discovered only through conscious
experience
it attempts to refute the theory that
all knowledge is physical knowledge
Professor Dennett also gave me
privileged access to his new draft paper
on cherry picking which you can think of
as a very similar concept to exploration
creativity and even experimentation then
it said that cherry picking or selecting
the best results is a crucial aspect of
decision making creativity and invention
both humans and AI systems like GPT
cherry pick but in different ways with
GPT he says cherry picking occurs during
the training process in the fine-tuning
stages although I personally kind of
disagree with that I mean I accept it's
a different mode of cherry picking as
one is during the formation of the
knowledge representation in the model
but there's something interesting about
cherry picking during inference as well
he also said that conscious human
invention relies on generating numerous
options and selecting the best ones a
bit like that tree of thought paper from
deepmind do you remember that it's
basically an a-star search over prompt
trajectories using the language model
itself as a value function so yeah we're
increasingly seeing models trained on
trajectories of reasoning paths as a
first-class citizen rather than actual
answers so that we know that they
predict the right things for the right
reasons and we can better understand
their reasoning process
now Dennis also said that cherry picking
processes are present in both an
individual's Consciousness and the
communication practices and he said that
there's resistance to accepting the
interpersonal nature of cherry picking
processes in creating our consciousness
he pointed out that the Elisa effect
demonstrates our instinct to discover
interpretations and that to make AI
capable of speech acts it must cherry
pick its own outputs with autonomy
he concluded that creating conscious
autonomous AI might be dangerous and
could conflict with human interests
anyway this brings us back full circle
to counterfeit people now he said that
AI should be used for smart machines not
artificial colleagues and that
preventing counterfeit AI individuals is
crucial for societal trust and security
he said that legal and technological
barriers are needed to protect against
the dangers of counterfeit AI creations
anyway with that said I hope you enjoy
the show today it's been an honor to
interview Professor Dennett enjoy
[Music]
welcome back to mlst ladies and
gentlemen we are here today with
Professor Daniel Dennett an American
philosopher writer and cognitive
scientist whose research primarily
focuses on the philosophy of Mind
philosophy of science and philosophy of
biology particularly as those fields
relate to evolutionary biology and
cognitive Science Now denit is in fact
arguably the most famous and important
living philosopher today and given our
particular interest in the philosophy of
mine can you only imagine how excited we
are for this opportunity
um Dennis also did his PhD under the
legendary Gilbert Ryle who coined the
term the ghost in the machine which
we've spoken about at Great length
recently particularly with respect to
Noam Chomsky
um so he's very well known in many
adjacent fields of science but today
we're going to be focusing on the theory
of mind and ethics now Dennett is a
strong advocate of a naturalistic and
materialistic approach to understanding
the mind and Consciousness and he's also
known for arguing that conscious
experiences are essentially the result
of complex computations carried out by
the brain which is to say he's a
computationalist you might say that the
his arch intellectual Nemesis is John
Cell now one of his Central theories is
the multiple drafts model of
Consciousness which suggests that there
is no single unified stream of
Consciousness but rather a series of
parallel processes occurring in the
brain which gives rise to our subjective
experience now throughout his career
Dennett has written several influential
and popular books on various topics
related to philosophy cognitive science
and evolution and some of his notable
Works include content and Consciousness
the intentional stance conscious
business explained Darwin's dangerous
idea Freedom evolves and from bacteria
to bark and back the evolution of Mines
now Dennett is currently professor of
philosophy and co-director of the center
of cognitive studies at Tufts University
he continues to be an influential
thinker and public intellectual
contributing to various debates
surrounding the Mind Evolution and the
role of religion in our society now
Professor Dennett has just published an
article in the Atlantic titled the
problem with counterfeit people he
argued that companies using AI to
generate fake people are committing an
immoral act of vandalism and should be
held liable now Nick from our Discord
Community expressed it as a continued
degradation of Social and ontological
coherence in a world-mediated by
software effectively good heart's law
reified in Evermore facets of Our Lives
Professor Dennett it's an absolute honor
to have you here could you tell us about
your article
I've been
writing increasingly
urgent warnings about the dangers of of
certain Trends in AI
and the one in the Atlantic
is meant to really Ring the Alarm Bell
uh
llm's chat Bots chat GPT and their Kim
are I think an extraordinarily dangerous
turn in the technology
uh because
they're good enough to fool people
they are good counterfeits of actual
interlocutors
and if
since we're spending so much of our time
online these days we're getting so much
of our of our interactions with people
online
uh we're suckers for
fake people online it's it's almost
impossible it is impossible that
to create a uh a fake person that
you know whose hand you can shake and
and whom you can
who's uh
uh perfume you can smell and and so
forth uh but virtual people uh
you on your end of the internet now and
me on mine it's becoming more and more
possible to fake those uh and
what a lot of people don't seem to
realize
is that
as
this becomes more a part of our reality
as more and more of these
fakes populate the virtual world
it's going to change our whole attitude
about
what we're doing right now
and we're going to become less trustful
we'll begin to kind of worried about
whether we're talking to the real thing
or or something else and either we're
going to get
paranoid and start asking gotsa
questions all the time trying to check
each other out to see if we're real
or we're just going to ignore
each other
pretty much and we're going to we're
going to lose the very connectivity
that we've just recently gained thanks
to the internet I think I think the the
Prospect of
harm serious
harm to the just the fabric of
civilization
it is right here and it's not because
AGI is going to enslave us
it's that we're going to let much much
stupider systems
beguile us and manipulate us and uh
generally
devalue the world of inner of
communication
yes indeed in many ways undermining our
weaknesses rather than overcoming our
strengths but some I wanted to pick up
on something about reversibility now you
said in your article that it will soon
be next to impossible to tell whether
text has been generated by human or not
and even if for the time being we're
able to teach one another reliable
methods of exposing counterfeit people
the cost of such deep fakes to human
trust will be enormous now I spoke with
Professor Luciano florito a floridi
recently and he discussed this concept
of reversibility he said when you come
to my house and you find clean dishes on
the table did I do the dish did I do the
dishes did the dishwasher do the dishes
I don't know he said and he defined
reversibility as from the answer I can
reverse to the actual identity of the
source an irreversible process is one
which doesn't let you do that and he
argued that language models are becoming
more irreversible by the day as as you
do which is to say they're making fewer
obvious mistakes although a tangential
issue is whether they have the capacity
to deceive us I think we'll touch on
that later but um on the other side
could be a human a group of humans a
human with a computer or chat GPT
um what's your take
well I think right now
we're still
fairly secure
I'm not seriously worried that I'm not
talking to you or that you were
a reasonable
communicative and constructive
interlocutor but that may change the
point is it could change
and if Bad actors and just
thoughtless actors
thinking they're having a lark uh make a
change
they'll they'll do a lot of damage
um
I was struck by a phrase in a a video
lecture
um uh by Eric horvitz the chief
scientific officer at Microsoft who
spoke about the post epistemic world
and that's
a chilling thought
no sooner do we create this wonderful
method of sending information around the
world
that we also invent methods of sending
misinformation around the world that we
can't that we can't tell from
information and we pollute our own
extended nervous systems uh you don't
have
we often say well are my eyes deceiving
me are my ears deceiving me
but we know that neither our eyes nor
our ears as it were have have ulterior
motives
if they if they're deceiving us it's
because of of a minor flaws in in their
uh
uh design that
have been tripped by some Illusions in
the in the uh external world but but
we're now entering an age where
deception
uh is much
more technically possible and of course
when it's technically possible they're
going to be people
who mindlessly use that possibility to
do all sorts of stunts some of which may
be really damaging
uh
I think it's the philosopher Kim
spirulny who writes about thought in the
heart in a hospital world who who says
basically we can
we can trust our eyes in our ears
because because we're all in the same
boat all right
it does not serve any useful purpose for
our eyes willfully to deceive us
um uh May
arise often do
help us uh uh
see things that we that are important to
us that we wouldn't otherwise see which
is great uh Evolution has done a
wonderful job of making our our
information facilities
tuned to the things that matter most to
our survival and well-being
that's a story in itself uh but when
we're now
challenging that
wonderful arrangement with all our
technology which can get out of our
control
yes I completely agree about the
epistemic deterioration and in a minute
I'm going to talk about ontological
deterioration but um I think something
we'll touch on as well is the extent to
which these systems are autonomous
whether they have agency or whether they
are tools and if they do have agency can
they deceive us because I think there's
a difference between a counterfeit human
and a counterfeit human with goals and
desires and intentionality and so on but
just coming on to this point about
reintologization which I think is very
interesting so again Luciano feridi said
that once digital immigrants like us are
replaced by digital natives like our
children the immigration will become
complete and future Generations will
increasingly feel deprived excluded and
handicapped or poor whenever they're
disconnected from the infosphere like
fish out of water and he said that these
Technologies like GPT are
re-ontologizing which is a more extreme
form of re-engineering us and our
society which is to say our intrinsic
nature is being transformed he argued
that it's modifying our everyday
perspective on the ultimate nature of
reality so our metaphysics from a
materialistic one where objects and
processes play a role to an
informational one so I mean do you agree
in principle with this idea of
re-ontologization
um I'm not sure it sounds a little
extreme but I don't know for sure what
what what uh Floridian in mind uh
I think that
on the positive side
the new technology
is
helping people
understand something that I've been
stressing for years namely that
our native equipment
has been designed by evolution
to create a sort of benign user illusion
the affordances to use James Gibson's
wonderful term the affordance is that we
just take for granted and pick up at
every child learns
in the course of the first couple of
years of life
we can now more easily see that our
affordances are already
biased by our senses
tuned to us so you know our colors real
and once that's yeah of course they're
real of course they're real
um uh we we aren't going to sue
uh
Sherwin-Williams paint company for false
advertising when they tell us they've
got paint in many different colors of
course they do color is as real as the
chips in the paint store on the other
hand you can't characterize color
independently of color perceivers
um color is
a phenomenon which requires
both generators and consumers in effect
it requires a particular sort of a user
and if you're colorblind
you're a different sort of user than if
you aren't
and if you were a tetrachromat like a
pigeon you'd be able to see colors that
you and I can't see and those colors are
just as real
they're just not visible to us
and they're not
independent
of their perceivers
I wanted
go ahead I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry I
wanted to ask you actually about this
dichotomy between
um you know realists like John so and
representationalists because I think
color perception is a great example of
that
um I mean John so would say when when
you tie up your shoes that really
happened and that the things that we
um perceive are actually in reality and
then you have people like Kant who say
the thing in itself you know which is
this idea that humans can't know the
world directly can only know it through
representations and and experiences and
of course human Barkley thought that
objects were collections of experiences
you know like a phenomenological
understanding but so you you are a
realist is that fair
um
I'm a realist about real patterns
okay uh
the same year that I published
Consciousness explained that published a
paper called real patterns which has
taken on a life of its own and the
science that's Mainland
um and I'd say what's real is any
pattern in the data that uh
you can uh bet on and make money on it
it's any it's any pattern which is uh
distinguishable from Randomness uh
uh better uh more compressed than the
bitmap
and uh
that's what reality is
and the idea that there's a deeper
deeper deeper deeper reality I guess
cut would be a good example of the uh
most worked out version of it I've
always found that to be
a bit of inflation
uh philosophers love to inflate things
and I'm I'm usually a deflationist
um I think
a lot of people think we don't have free
will because as Jerry folder once said
uh we want to be suffering that even God
couldn't tell whether Eve was going to
eat into the bite into the Apple
um
no we don't care about that we nor
should we we want to be as unpredictable
as we have to be so that we can't be
manipulated by others
and we want to we know we want to keep
our cards close to our chest we don't
want to have tells as a poker player
would say uh uh we want to
Reserve our
planning and our sense of what the
options are what we know what we don't
know we want to reserve that to
ourselves that's what our autonomy
depends on and that's what our Free Will
depends on and what philosophers often
want to uh
think that the way they to get to the
root of the thing is is to go extreme to
become absolutists of whatsoever another
and then to wring their hands about it
I hadn't really thought about this but
it
um maybe I'm putting words in your mouth
but it seems a bit like you're saying
there's an existential imperative to be
unpredictable and maybe one of the
problems with large language models
being able to predict us with such high
fidelity as it kind of erodes our
autonomy because there's this
adversarial actor out there who knows
what we're going to do
yeah if you hadn't thought of it in that
in those terms too but of course
you and I
are
able to have this conversation because
we're pretty good at predicting
the next word out of my
my what
your mouth yes of course
I I was hoping you were going to jump in
there a little faster
um
husbands and wives can often finish each
other's sentences it's not a bad thing
uh
all that's what brains are for it's for
predicting
and uh we'd be
hopelessly out of the loop if we weren't
engaged in one might even say aggressive
anticipation all the time we don't have
to worry about it takes care of itself
it's part of our automatic brain
functioning
uh
and
autonomy
is enlargement or a matter of
keeping the highest levels of your of
your motivational systems to yourself
and
uh
exploiting
deterministic chaos
Litecoin basically basically it's good
to have it's good to have coin flippers
in your head and and for a very very
simple reason for the same reason that
computers
have randomized it
and
call for random variables a lot and the
reason they do is when you don't know
what to do
you don't want to be stuck like
bearden's ass Frozen between eating and
drinking because you're both hungry and
thirsty you flip a coin
and
we need
Randomness in that
water downsets it's not Quantum
Randomness it's not indeterminism it's
just a source of bits that's orthogonal
to or independent of whatever it is that
we're thinking about
That's the basis for statistical design
of experiments in science
and it's uh how we choose the next words
out of our mouths uh we
uh in one of my books I I I I tell the
tale of myself when I was in grade
school and learned how to do long
division
and was initially shocked when when the
teacher said
you want to know how many times
379 goes into
two million and six
you know what he wrote put down for your
first she said just guess
just randomly guess
blurted out and then you test and if
it's too much you change your guess if
it's to literally change your guess that
random step in long division is a
perfect model of something we have to do
and then our brains do all the time
we're doing it right now in your brain
right now
well I'm going to say just
for fun
thousands
of possible continuations of this
discussion are are unconsciously
trying to get themselves into the
conversation right now
and now when I let you talk what comes
out is going to be
something that's won a competition uh in
in a partially chaotic uh opponent
process
well so I I think um because you're
you're um slightly touching on your
cherry picking draft and we can talk
about that in a minute but that's
somewhat analogous to exploration and I
also want because I know you're a famous
philosopher of science as well and and
in my mind science is about generating
um intelligible explanations about
things and you're just looking yeah and
I think you were just talking about what
I would call abduction which is about
kind of like creating a plausible
hypothesis space that's the really
mysterious part and then we do the
strong and the weak syllogisms where we
do deduction and induction uh a lot of
people don't talk about the the
abduction part but I also wanted to talk
about what you were saying before so
prediction is this kind of Continuum and
you could be a complete empiricist a
blank slate person and you're just
looking at Raw sensory information but
even with your long division example
there was this flash of inspiration or
maybe you were given the knowledge or
you acquired the knowledge of the
structure of how to perform that
reasoning and then suddenly the way your
cognition handled that problem was
changed dramatically and it's very
similar to Noam Chomsky being a
rationalist he thinks that we have this
structure kind of built into us and it
would be impossible to think without the
structure so yeah how much structure do
we need
oh that's a good question
um
uh
well let me reflect on on charmsky for
just for just a moment maybe that will
bring my thinking and a better focus on
this
um yes gnome is a is a an ardent
rationalist
and uh
he seems not to appreciate
that
rationalism taken neat the way he seems
to want to take it cut Descartes with
it is uh
it's
it's a dead end
um and and actually Descartes figured
this out
Descartes in the meditations
uh
realizes that he's going to need
a non-deceiving god
to guarantee his clear and distinct
ideas his his rationalistic structure if
if God's deceiving him he's in deep
trouble
and so he has to so he has to cook up
these
Preposterous arguments to the existence
of God just in order to satisfy himself
that that he can trust trust his own
thought
on the other side there's those of us
who are who believe that this is a not a
solitary Venture it's a communal Venture
and I trust my thought to some degree
but I trust your thoughts at some degree
and I am willing to have you offer
suggestions that will correct what I'm
saying and this process of mutual
constructive discussion
is the best way we have
to get clear about
Truth uh an old friend of mine Roger
wertheimer once wrote about what he
called the fact you Norm principle factu
Norm is a
not a very
friendly term but that's what he called
it and that's the very business of
talking to each other as we're doing
that as we're doing that
presupposes that we think we know that
this is a way to get at the truth
otherwise why do we need to do it we
go play tennis or something like that uh
there'd be no point in having this
discussion if we didn't think
that how we do carry on discussion is it
is also normative that's how we ought to
do it
but of course that's a
a correctable process it's defeasable we
can learn new methods we can we can
change our logical system we can
discover
um irrational numbers and then and uh
imaginary numbers like hi and
the process of invention grows out of
this turn of interaction with other
thinkers
and uh
no seems to think that
he wants to be a Cartesian
and I want to be a darwinian
and I think uh that's
a really fun and little divide once you
get on to Darwin
you realize that the Cartesian route is
is a a brilliant dead end
the other day I was talking with
somebody about this and I um
I put for her the sort of rude thought
that Descartes has the honor
of having
been
in a way the wrongest thinker ever
um
he
his principia
inspired Newton
who thought the occurred but just dead
wrong and of course Descartes was just
dead wrong in his physics and Newton but
but Descartes inspired Newton to come up
for the Newtonian visits
Descartes is also dead wrong in a way
that Darwin corrected so without
Descartes uh
we might not have had Newton and Darwin
who I think is the two greatest in
thinkers of all time
just before we leave this topic I mean
of course you you were supervised by
Gilbert um Ryle he coined the term the
ghost in the machine who's very famous
for
um criticizing Descartes actually and
I'm sure he had a huge inspiration on uh
you know inspired a lot of your thought
as well but I just wondered if you could
just give me a few comments on on what
that was like
my Gilbert Ryan and our interactions was
like yes yes yeah well
um
I go into this in
more detail in my forthcoming memoir
called I've been thinking uh
which would be out in the fall but I I
confessed that
I first of all Ryle was a hero of mine
already when I was in undergraduate I
thought the concept of mine was maybe
the best philosophy book I'd ever read
so I was very thrilled to be working
with Ron but then when I met him
I was initially
uh
frustrated to discover I couldn't get
him to argue with me
he it was like punching a pillow
I'd try to pick a fight and he'd say oh
yes yeah yes and he'd offer a few
examples and he just
can't
he I guess
in a couple of years working with him he
sort of cured me of the philosophers
combativeness
and
gave me a model of constructive
thinking but I didn't appreciate it at
the time
and
when my fellow graduate students asked
me what it was like to work with Ryan I
said well
he's great at cheering me up and taking
me on and I'll go to see him and I'll be
all Crest following and thinking I
should get out of the field and come out
of this study thinking okay I can do
this I can do this
um but I don't think I've learned
anything from him
and then I looked at a draft
of my dissertation that I'd written
early and then I looked at the draft
that I handed in
and miles
fingerprints were all over that he'd had
a tremendous but
almost subliminal influence on my
thinking
interesting do you think fats um the
combativeness in science or maybe in
philosophy is a bit like the learning
right in the neural network it increases
the philosophy of learning or do you
think it's somewhat orthogonal to that
oh well I think combative Mrs is
required but there's combativeness and
then there's just
pugilism
and
I I call it fisticuffs and I spell it
with a pH
and that's what a lot of philosophers
whole careers are just fisticuffs
and uh
uh I I really
have very little patience for that
defining your term serving I've got a
counter example but what a lot of
philosophers uh call a theory I call a
slogan
that's all it is it's a refined
counter example proof slogan and the
only tests that's ever passed is that
nobody can think of a counter example to
it uh
that's not the way to make progress
uh but but
absolutely competition is required
um think of Andrew Wiles proof of
fairmont's Last Theorem
yeah for hundreds of years people have
thought they'd improved
fairmont's Last Theorem
but those who thought so were mainly
somewhat deranged they were going crazy
if you think you've proved fairmont's
Last Theorem
you've got to consider the disjunction
either I have proved pheromones Last
Theorem or I'm going crazy
and you have to take the second conjunct
very seriously
the only thing that could or should
convince Andrew Wiles that he'd
succeeded was that his fellow
mathematicians his competitors
graciously conceded after
going
pouring Untold hours of
oppositional work into seeing if they
could find any flaws and there's in this
proof that's how you do that's how you
do science that's how you do mathematics
even even mathematics the we have to
remember that there's a there's a social
side
to mathematics
nobody would trust arithmetic if he
doesn't have all the experience with it
being used to count cows and apples and
to balance your checkbook it works it
works
the empirical
evidence that arithmetic works is in the
end but really
grounds our conviction and that not any
any proofs
about the consist you know about the
consistency of arithmetic
um I I wanted to move over to your and
two black boxes thought experiment would
you mind um just briefly framing it up
and then we'll go from there
um
yes this this thought experiment was uh
designed to show
in a way the inner limitability of the
intentional stance
or the the the the the practical
uh necessity of using it so I imagine
that we find these two black boxes box a
and box B and they're connected with a
wire
like I'm going to keep this comically
simple
um there's a few buttons two buttons on
uh box a and three lights on box B
and you press button a alpha and box a
and
box B there upon either trying to a red
light or a green light
or very very occasionally uh an Amber
like
and uh the scientists want to figure out
they they run a few billion trials and
they figure out that
whatever the cause of the lights going
on on box B it's coming through this
wire if you cut the wire of course it
doesn't it it's no interaction anymore
but when they uh when they look at
what's in The Wire
it's a it's a bit string
uh I can't remember how long I said in
my original not that bitstream was but
you know some thousands of bits
um
and uh
then they look in the boxes and they
find that the each one has a program in
it they're computers
but they're they're different computers
the hardware is different their software
is different
and uh so and we can suppose that
apps and then emmanuels these are quite
inscrutable
to to the computer science it's
uh
but they check
and then when they had the whole thing
all set up learning everybody agrees
tracing through with the micro level
that the cause of the green light going
on or the red light going on is is
determined in no magical way just by
everyday hand simulation with flip-flops
so forth all the way through so there's
no mystery here there's no morphic
resonances or spiritual interventions
well then finally they find out
uh
how the thing works
um
these are these are go Phi systems
the time I wrote it at llms didn't exist
um weren't even really imagined
um so they're boxes of truths they're
boxes of World Knowledge uh box a might
be uh uh inspired by Don Doug Glenn it's
Psych
project of many years ago to try to
encode everyday World Knowledge in the
program by hand coding in any case
these are two independent
efforts to create a box of Truth
and what's being passed down the wire is
just
the signal
send a true sentence down the wire if
you push button the red button or the a
button send a false foot down
and those falsehoods are true that are
pulled by the randomizer out of the box
so if you push the true button on box a
maybe it'll say
um uh
um
Cincinnati is a city in Ohio that's true
and if you if you have asked for a false
sentence it might say
um
giraffes are a kind of fish you know
okay
that's all
and the other box simply tests for truth
or falsehood against its own box of
Truth
but otherwise the the systems are as
distinct as you could make them now what
I claim is
you have to go to the semantic level to
understand how this system works
you have to have the concepts of meaning
and Truth reference
uh when I first trotted this experiment
out at a at a conference at Santa Fe
Institute Danny Phyllis my old friend
was there and he said oh I get it he
said that
this is cryptography using the world as
a one-time path
that's exactly right uh and uh
the reality of semantics is if you got
it
You can predict like a son of the many
circumstances very easy
by adopting the intentional stance and
treating these things as passing
information on various topics in the
world it works the patterns are real uh
they may be entirely inscrutable uh at
lower levels if you want to understand
the stock market
don't go to the level of microphysics
and try to trace it through the brains
of all the players
all the stock brokers in the world
much better off to treat them as agents
with beliefs and desires and then you'll
have you'll be able to make some
prophecies which are way better than
chance coming out
and I'm sorry if this seems like a
ridiculous distinction but using the
model of beliefs and desires is
presumably different to thinking they
have beliefs and desires not much
that much
um
here's where my uh darwini and
gradualism as usual comes in
um
actually one of The Inspirations from my
uh intentional stance was when the
computer programmer Rich Greenblatt we
were at the AI Lab at MIT and he said of
a
chest pain program early test playing
program they're things that should get
its Queen out early
and everybody in the room understood
what he meant
and everybody realized there was no
sentence
in any language in that program which
you would translate as I should get my
queen out early or anything like that
the beliefs
but the sense in which the test program
believed it should get its Queen out
early is pretty much the same sense that
you believe a lot of things that you
believe I mean one of the things that
you believe is that zebras in the wild
don't wear hats
I hadn't told you anything you didn't
already know
do you think that belief was do you
think that belief was encoded in your
head no no no no
um but it's simply part of your World
Knowledge
that that you know that you don't know
when you learned it nobody told you that
uh
and
most
of the information that
guides our everyday life
has that occupied that kind of role in
our brains we do of course learn things
by being told things
here's where we get closer to GPS
I mean GPT
um
uh language is what opens up
The Unbelievable wealth of knowledge
that
anybody in the world now can share
uh but uh
it all rests on this
uh more animal foundation of uh
information about the world
which
is the information we need
to take care of ourselves
interesting okay a few things on that
then
um there's knowledge and there's syntax
and as so said some knowledge is
epistemically subjective like economics
and you were talking about Chess which
is very interesting because I I know um
as a philosopher you've you're
incredibly well known for thinking about
how purpose and intentionality and
meaning arises and I actually asked my
friend Professor Mark Bishop for for
comment on on some of this stuff he
found a comment online actually about
your black box thought experiment by a
professional philosopher and um they
they said that it showed how the
properties red green and Amber weren't
really semantical or mentalistic after
all but only imitation semantical
properties as if semantical properties
basically very complicated meaningless
and tactical properties and then you
responded why draw such a distinction
but but the the main thrust though where
I want to go with this is this idea of
the meaning of computation being
Observer relative so there was an
example from I think Winograd and Floors
they use the chess computer which can
play chess and they used it to control
lights in an art exhibition so
um you know Mark would say it's
meaningless until put to human use you
know when it's plugged into the wider
cognitive Ecology of where the machines
play a part that imbues the meaning what
do you think about that
I think it's anthropocentric in a in an
indefensible way
um
uh
when a um I mean let's let's take let's
take an example which is deliberately
very simple let's think about Bayesian
mimicry and let's think that there's a
poisonous snake that has a bright red
band I can't remember the names of the
snakes bright red band around its neck
which
is very important because it's
poisonousness
uh wouldn't help it if if it wasn't
notoriously poisonous and this is its
warning that it's poisonous
and then there's an other species of
snakes which also have a red band on
theirs and they they're parasitic on the
first
uh they mimic the poisonous variety
um
and and get a a fitness benefit
from
being
close to indistinguishable
from the poisonous variety so they they
they're freeloading on the uh poison
generating capacity of the poisonous
species now
is there a semantics area of course
um
if you want to make sense
if you want to make sense of that
if you if you imagine you know a March
and just finding these two
snakes
in the world
and seeing they both have a red stripe
and you ask why
why
well that question is ambiguous there's
a how come asking and there's a what for
it I go into that in a lot more detail
in from back period of back to back
um
the how come
explanation would require
a an account of millions of years of
evolution
the what for explanation
cuts to the Chase and says what I just
told you namely
this is an adaptation because
the information that the snake is
poisonous which deters
predators
is also deters them from going through
the non-poisonous thing this is an
instance of deception
that's semantic
well this is really interesting because
I wanted to um zoom in a little bit on
the reasons for this argument for
counterfeit people and one angle is
really interesting I hadn't thought of
before is this concept of semantic
Capital so it's almost as if you think
that overloading and the semantic
Capital creates a vulnerability just
like it did with the snake mimicking the
venomous snake there's a semantic
Capital which can be used and deceived
that we have
oh gosh yes I mean this this is an idea
that goes back to my original
intentional assistance paper where I
said
um we take out a loan of intelligence
we take out a loan of semantics and it
it very valuable it it simplifies our
our uh
picture of the World by orders of
magnitude
but then of course it creates
vulnerabilities uh
it means that
we can be fooled
and if
if anything the intentional stance has
proven to be as I said from the outside
the sort of instinct it's it's
our capacity our
proclivity to use the intentional stance
to try to understand anything that's
complex
um
is well established that's why
I mean why around the world
do uh
stone age did Stone Age people have rain
gods and Sun gods and and so forth
because these were phenomenal that they
were that were important to them that
they couldn't understand and so they
they thought well maybe we can pray to
them maybe we can argue with them maybe
we can make a deal uh you give me rain
and I'll sacrifice a a goat to you uh
the use of the intentional stance
is such a winner
but it's also vulnerable you're you're
you're it's risky it's it's uh
you you you get your purchase at a price
of risk
I wanted to bring another couple of
things in here so um I'm I'm a student
of the Chinese room argument and I'm not
sure we've got time to go into it into
detail but I know that you
um you got on board with the systems
reply which is basically thinking of uh
you know rather than a person you think
of the entire system you know system
understanding and then of course you you
framed the intentional uh stance
um which is that you know we treat it as
an intelligent agent capable of
understanding there is this virtual mind
as well which that it can successfully
simulate the behavior of a human that
understands Chinese so it's a virtual
mind and use a distributed cognition but
I guess where I want to go with this
though is that you famously kind of
argued against this notion
um that to have true understanding you
need to have this kind of strange
phenomenal Consciousness that could only
exist in real humans and couldn't exist
in silico and just the conversation
we've had now about the black box
experiment you you said that we can
think of the black boxes as having
mental States so in in some sense their
agents maybe even moral agents and
perhaps given that they are simulated
human agents we might even say that
um you know that they might be moral
human agents so I guess given this why
do we designate them counterfeit if you
think they're not actually counterfeit
and and then the question is is there a
useful distinction between
um counterfeit people and real people oh
yes oh good well first of all the two
black boxes I deliberately said they're
not agents they're just boxes of true
zip one of my slogans in recent years
has been we want smart machines not
artificial colleagues
because artificial colleagues or agents
in a strong sense
um the boxes and the two black boxes the
only thing they can do is is
the pup a bit string down a wire and uh
the other one turns on the light those
are those are uh one-dimensional
agents we could make agents
that are multi-dimensional we could make
agents that were autonomous
uh that could worry about whether we
unplugged them and could decide that
they wanted to preserve their own future
uh and would try to rest control of
their on off switches from us and so
forth and those are possible in
principle but we aren't there yet the
llms for instance are not autonomous
agents they have no morality they they
are not
moral agents at all
but they could be parts of future
they could be stepping stones
to Future artificial agents that really
are autonomous
yes I I guess the reason for my
confusion was when we adopted this
intentional stance we project goals and
beliefs and so on and and it's intuitive
to me that agentiveness is a Continuum
and even a large language model it could
be a component in a larger architecture
which can act in the real world I think
you said once on a podcast that Watson
has less gentiveness than a robot
yes
um
to that though does that not imply that
there is a non-zero amount of
agentiveness in those black boxes
there's a non-zero amount of
attentiveness in the bacteria
in in a motor protein
as usual I'm going to play the
gradualist card yeah sure
um uh somebody I can't remember who one
of my uh former students or colleagues
suggested that the way to think about
about
llms is uh that oh it was Keith Frankish
who who said this uh he said think of
them as as playing the chat game
it's like playing chess
they're just trying to win the chat game
that's our only goal
and and they're pretty good at it
that's a bit of attentiveness but they
don't have any other goals
yeah yeah
um Professor Dennett I don't know
whether you've got another few minutes
I've got another question or if you need
to go ahead and go ahead I'll thank you
so much we'll we'll do one on
singularitarianism which I think is
quite interesting so
um the the AI risk debate has been
ongoing since the 1960s When Irvin John
good prophesies to potential
intelligence explosion which could leave
Humanity behind and on one side are
those who believe in true AI known as
the singularitarians or doomers and on
the other side of those who do not
believe in true AI known as the Church
of the AI atheists now the um the dogma
of the singularitarians consists of
three beliefs that creation of some form
of AI is likely that Humanity will be
dominated or destroyed by it and it's
the responsibility of the current
generation to ensure it's benign now
some have argued that it's implausible
when it distracts from real evils and
it's a bit of an Indulgence basically
now this is quite interesting because
when it comes to traditional religion
you are perhaps the world's most famous
atheist what's your take on single
first of all I think my dear friend
Richard Dawkins would be well yeah
would be a a better candidate for that
for that great honor but uh I certainly
join him in my wholehearted
atheism
um
I thought
since I first heard about the
singularity
that this was
a dangerous distraction because
even if in some philosophical sense it's
a possible in principle
it's uh and it may not be I think the
very idea of AGI is is
dubiously coherent
but even if it's possible in principle
long before we get there
non-agis things which are not a
singularity May dumb us down May exploit
us may distract us made it may pollute
the epistemic environment in ways that
we from which we can't recover
so
it's
it's like the Maginot Line
uh
you don't want don't plan ahead for the
singularity and try to cut it off deal
with the problems that are here right
now they're bad enough and they don't
requiring you to believe in the
singularity
just in closing a lot of a lot of these
deep learning folks who but who believe
in the singularity they place a lot of
faith in deep learning in particular and
they don't know much about some of the
stuff that we're talking about around
semantics and intentionality and you
know and how meaning emerges for example
and so himself said that a lot of
professional philosophers don't
understand these Concepts well and and I
believe they're very important
um for AI development and some people
have even commented on our Chomsky show
and Gary Marcus show saying oh what do
these guys know about AI as if all of
this semantic stuff is not relevant
anymore so did do you think that um you
know deep learning folks could learn a
little bit from philosophy
well it depends which philosophers they
listen to of course
they listen to me yes
um but if they of course but if they if
they listen to Cyril they're being led
down the Garden Path
um uh
Cyril has I think an upside down theory
of semanticity uh uh it's right out
there in the open uh uh and and David
Chalmers another one of my the friendly
opponents uh I think
his idea of the heart problem is a deep
distraction there's no hard problem
there's lots of hard questions which
we're working on but the idea that
there's this
hard fast bright line between things
that have phenomenal Consciousness and
things that don't that's that's just a
theorist's illusion
look it's like it's like it's like
vitalism as I've been saying for years
biologists pretty much have stopped
arguing about
the definition of life
you know our our motor proteins a lot
they're just proteins proteins how about
viruses and ALS who who cares
we understand the gradual Continuum that
takes you from proteins to amoebas
to
donkeys to people
and where you draw the line for life is
not very important because
viruses let's say they're not alive but
boy they they evolve
there's one thing we know is the natural
selection
covers them
beautifully
right now as we talk
you have trillions
the viruses in you
most of them almost all of them are
doing you know him they're just alive
for the ride
the Consciousness is like life
the idea that the world is divided into
things that are conscious whether it's
something it's like to be them and
everything else
is just a theorist's illusion like the
idea that there's a bright line between
the living and the not living
so we can say yeah yeah there's there's
reactivity there's sensitivity there's
the APT use of information in the
bacteria there's lots I mean bacteria
can be pretty dinosaur
um it's and
your intelligence and your Consciousness
is a
magnificent product of the interaction
of trillions of little agents one time I
was interviewed by Julio jarello a
wonderful science journalist and
philosopher in Italy and the headline in
the paper the next day was
yes we have a soul
but it's made of lots of tiny robots
exactly
exactly that's it that's that's my
that's my my motto uh yeah and
semanticity comes along
gradually
of course because it evolves like
everything else
I'm also a gradualist when it comes to
Consciousness but uh charm has said to
me in in New Orleans well there's no
consciousness meter you can't kind of
have a meter and wave it over someone's
face but we can measure Consciousness in
in a brain using equipment but the thing
that interests me is more about this
notion of conceivability there's this
other Minds problem in philosophy and
Nagel spoke about what's it like to be a
bat and so on and even even Chomsky
talks about the limits of our human
cognition do you think that's an issue
that we can't conceive of what it's like
to be another mind oh but I think we can
oh we can yes
um
um years ago
uh my uh research associate Kathleen
Aikens and I
set out to write a paper called what
it's like to be about we can know
everything worth knowing about what it's
like to be about if we really said about
it it's it's all going to be third
person science because that's
the way science works
and the idea that there's
going to be a missing ingredient is
another one of those uh absolutist
philosophical myths look philosophers
want to protect their territory
and the trouble is that they don't have
that many tools at their disposal
once you can prove from the armchair
without help from any of the Sciences is
is pretty thin grow
and uh yes it's possible to make
conceptual advances in a very rarified
conceptual environment where where you
don't know very much but
uh philosophers uh
usually usually not often but usually
end up confusing
mistaking Affair of imagination for an
insight into necessity
that if they knew a little bit more
they'd be able to imagine all a lot more
is is it one thing though to say that
there's this impenetrable Realm of the
subject of experience that is completely
it eludes us entirely and another thing
just to say okay it really does exist
it's very very complicated and we simply
can't conceive of it that seems like a
distinction
seems like one
[Laughter]
amazing
I don't think it is
interesting interesting um Professor
Daniel thank you so much I can't tell
you what what an honor it has been for
you to come on my podcast you're a hero
of mine I really really appreciate it
well you've asked good questions and
you've
it's been it's been useful talking with
you very much so but this is what a good
conversation should be thank you so much